foreign
for those in the audience just to let
you know we're going to get started soon
but we just we need to we need to make
some copies of stuff so just give us a
couple of minutes okay thanks
all right um I'm going to call the uh
executive session of the house Judiciary
Committee to order and I'm going to
first recognize representative Alexander
to lead us in the Pledge of Allegiance
foreign
all right
um so the first matter on for
consideration is SB 27 relative to
financial disclosure forms filed by
judges and I'm going to uh recognize
representative Perez for emotion
thank you I would like to move Senate
Bill 27 as it exists for ought to pass
is there a second
been made in seconds
um is representative Perez would you
like to speak to the motion or I'm not
sure if it needs to be but you're more
than welcome to if you wish to
it eliminates some paperwork
and makes life a little easier
no no that's right and you know I guess
I would just follow up on that a little
bit I think
um when I was still on the in the
judicial branch I uh I was appointed to
serve on a number of of committees that
of executive branch and or legislative
executive and and got uh and although I
had filed a judicial branch Financial
disclosure form it was always a question
of whether or not I had to file this
additional one I think I think I
normally did it because I wanted just
out of an abundance of caution and I
think other judges did the same thing
but I'm not sure that all of them did
and there definitely was some confusion
I can remember having conversations with
uh uh Bill Gardner about you know do I
have to do this for this or not so I
just think this kind of uh
it eliminates paperwork and since the
judicial form actually requires more
information than than the legislative
form I don't think there's a problem so
I think it's a good idea
um any any further discussion on this
are we ready for a vote
all right then I guess I'd ask the clerk
if the police call the roll
Vice chairman Wallace yes
rep Alexander yes
rep Andrews yes rep testerman
rep Stapleton yes rep trip yes
rep Grayson yes
clerk votes yes rep Perez yes
rep Smith
reporgan yes rep dilorenzo yes rep Kenny
yes
reppage
rep Eaton
rep Lanza
yes
rep Manos
repter yes
chairman Lynn yes
19-0 motion passes
objectives being
I hope he placed on consent
um
and uh
representative profession I ask you to
write the uh a little blurb on it thank
you
report report
so 2020.
all right
all right next um
we'll turn to uh SB 59 relative to the
director of charitable trusts and the
chair recognizes uh representative
Alexander thank you Mr chair I move
OTP and move Amendment uh
2023-1404 H right there a second
hey second the motion
yes speak to your Amendment yes so um
this amendment
um
is a I I believe it will help strengthen
the bills so the bill as it is uh
removes the physical location and the
Attorney General had no problem
um
the reason for the physical location in
the argument is it was archaic or like
there was really no reason to have a
meeting necessary at the state house
um but I did see the Merit in having a
physical Location meeting if the person
being investigated would like it so this
amendment basically would allow any any
person or all these other people
um that are being investigated to have a
a right to have an appearance in a
physical location but it still gives the
Attorney General the opportunity to
determine
um the actual location so I believe it
will strengthen the bill
um removing the at the State House in
the original bill
um we'll remove the
the requirement that's at the state
house but I believe adding in my
Amendment will allow the person being
investigated to have a physical meeting
and um the reason why I believe that
this is important is because
the Attorney General's office said that
you know they sometimes have hearings
over Zoom or our investigations over
zoom and I think most people would feel
like that is
a valid investigation but not all people
and I think if
some requests that they should be
investigating in person they should have
a right to that right to do that so I
just want to cover the basics and I
think this amendment strengthens the
bill while covers what the Attorney
General's office wanted so I ask that
you've supported
I'm sorry representative Smith
thank you very much Mr chair
um I always prefer to agree with my
um my colleague from Goffstown whenever
I can which is most often and I will in
fact agree with him on this amendment
although I don't really believe it's
necessary I am happy to support
his um request that we amend the bill
anyone else wish to speak on the
amendment
all right do we need to do a roll call
on the amendment okay all right so then
I'm gonna can I just ask on the
amendment
um to for by show of hands all those in
favor of the amendment please raise your
hand
any opposed
so it's 18 I'm sorry I guess it would be
19 to 1 uh in favor of the amendment
um
second
just making some notes Here
all right then we're now on to uh the
main motion
um on the uh on the bill as amended
anyone else wish to speak to
uh the the main bill as uh amended
saying no one are we ready for a vote
all right so I could ask the clerk
police to call the roll
Vice chairman Wallace yes rep Alexander
rep Andrews yes rep testerman
rep Stapleton yes reptrip yes rep
Grayson
clerkatab votes yes rep Perez yes
rep Smith
Oregon yes rep D Lorenzo yes rep Kenny
YES Prep page
rep Eaton
rep Divine yes rep Lanza yes rep Manos
yes Rapture yes
chairman Lynn yes
motion passes 20-0
uh consent any any problem with that
sent and uh representative Alexander can
you write the report yes Mr chair thank
you
all right
um and we're next on to
um SB 65
uh this is the bill uh repealing the uh
medical screening panels and uh the
chair recognizes representative top for
emotion
I move OTP
for a second
moved by representative second by
representative Wallace representative do
you wish to speak to your motion
briefly yes please
it just became very clear that these
panels aren't being used and
after hearing all the testimony I was
unable to even see a path forward about
how it could even be made to work I
think there's so
a few Specialists and certain of these
you know specialized
practices that you wouldn't be able to
find somebody that didn't have a
conflict of interest within the state
and it's just not practical
to have and I think it was just becoming
a wasteful if at some other point
another idea is thought of about how to
make something like this work I think we
can certainly pursue it at that point
but leaving something in that's just
simply not working and not being used
and hasn't done anything over the years
to just decrease the
amount of malpractice insurance
um
payments or anything like that then I I
just I don't see the use in it so I um
I think repealing it is the right thing
to do
anyone else wish to be heard on
um sb65 and I guess I would just very
briefly having been involved after the
when the legislature first
adopted this I was on the superior court
and it was Superior Court that was
charged with uh was sort of implementing
the statute and we put in
a great deal of work to get the system
up and running and I know it's and it it
still continues to involve on the part
of the judicial branch a fair amount of
work because as I understand it most of
these hearings are that that are waived
are waived relatively late in the
process after the judicial branch at
least has put in a fair amount of work
um and I think my my
take on it is that from the perspective
of the judicial branch
they they they made a good faith effort
to to implement the statute as written I
think they I think from their
perspective they did that and it just it
as representative Qatar points out it
just has not been used it hasn't really
accomplished
um
its original goals and so high for that
reason I I and I think the witnesses
that we heard at the hearing really made
a compelling case of why the Senate's
decision to repeal it is one that we
should follow so I I support the uh
uh the motion any anyone else wish to be
heard on this
all right I guess we're ready for a vote
then uh I asked the clerk to please call
the roll
base chairman Wallace yes
rep Alexander yes rep Andrews yes rep
testerman yes rep Stapleton yes reptrick
yes rep Grayson yes clerkatab votes yes
rep Perez
rep Smith
reporgan yes
rep Delorenzo
yes
rep Kenny yes
that page
rep Eaton
rep Divine yes replanza yes rep Manos
yes repter yes
chairman Lynn yes
motion passes 20-0
and consent any any objection to it
being on consent
all right
next we'll move on uh to
um
SB
this is um
relative to accommodate accommodation
for medical reasons in issuing marriage
licenses and
um
I'm gonna uh
recognize
I can find it now
it's just uh
1605 yes I'm going to recognize myself
uh
to move uh ought to pass as amended and
I and I would offer Amendment uh
1605 h
um which I'd like to speak to if there's
a second to my motion
Stapleton seconds all right so um
this is you may recall that this was the
bill
um that um
its purpose is to Grant uh City and town
clerks the authority to um
to uh
um not have to have someone come to
their office uh for the purpose of uh
issuing
um a marriage license and the the way
the bill came to us from the Senate was
it it it required the clerk to make an
accommodation to parties uh by meeting
either in person or electronically with
the parties
um the prime sponsor of the bill Senator
uh bird cell indicated that there was at
least
some confusion as to how the word shell
as opposed to May got into the bill
because the the uh the original intent
had been May to give the clerk's
discretion to decide whether to make an
accommodation or not
um and Senator Bert cell urged us to go
back to that may as opposed to Shell
because she felt that the clerk should
have discretion to not do this if they
felt that there was some
you know that something just didn't seem
right about the request
um uh and so I think
my sense from the was it the committee
thought that was a good idea to go back
to May and then the other issue that was
raised
was that people had concern people on
the committee had concerns about the
electronically about allowing this to be
done electronically and my understanding
again that was that those concerns were
on vote really on boat there were there
was sort of a bipartisan concern
regarding that and so for that reason I
took that out so that the the
um the the way the amendment reads now
it says um and I'm quoting now it's
either party is unable to appear in
person for documented medical reasons
the city or town clerk May accommodate
the parties by meeting in person with
the parties at such other location
within the city or town as may be
convenient and I think that addresses
the various concerns that were that were
raised
um and so uh for that reason I I hope
people will support the amendment
anyone else wish to speak on the
amendment
seeing none um I guess I would ask for a
show of hands then uh all those in favor
of this amendment please raise your hand
any opposed
seeing none it was appears it's a
unanimous uh 20 to o on the amendment
just making some notes Here
all right I guess we're ready for a uh
anyone else wish to speak on the main
main bill
Just one thought that I have is it says
documented medical reasons but it
doesn't really say how medical reasons
would be documented or who gets to make
the decision about whether they are or
not that's my one concern that I have
looking at this is is it's it's opening
up the door for having to disclose you
know private medical information but
it's not really clear what needs to be
disclosed or or how or who or to whom
I don't know if anyone has thoughts on
that representative
so I think that was one of the big
reasons for making it say May so that
the clerk would have the discretion to
accept it or not because let's say in
the example of a nursing home it may be
completely reasonable to accept medical
documentation from an RN stating that
the person is incapacitated in in a
nursing home right versus
in another circumstance where somebody's
not in that it may be more reasonable to
expect a note from a physician so that
gives the leeway of the clerk to accept
if something's reasonable or not
depending on the circumstances and from
the testimony we heard it seemed as if
the clerks were wanting this because
they wanted to be able to provide this
service to you know residents that maybe
having a medical issue and and wanting
to get married so it didn't seem like
they were going to be searching for
reasons not to accept but that if
something came across that you know
appeared to be potentially fraudulent or
something like that then in that case
they would have the discretion to say
I'm uncomfortable with this you would
need to come in as as normal
yes uh representative Smith and then
representative Perez thank you very much
I agree with what the clerk said I would
also add to the clerk's comments and in
response to the initial question
um that
um
using clerk in the different sense
the clerks who were the subject of this
um have to deal with a confidential
material all the time and are quite I
believe Adept at making sure that they
do not have a direct pipeline to
um any
any public
body to
inappropriately share
medical
reports and I think it is very helpful
to have the language as flexible as
possible because we rely on those
elected clerks to use good judgment
representative Perez
thank you for taking my response um
medical diagnosis HIPAA violations do
not need to occur in this at all all you
need is that there is a medical reason
is the only reason having managed the
New England Heart Institute at one time
I wrote many of these to be signed by
the doctor and you do not have to give a
reason you just have to say that there
is medically necessary
and so hipic doesn't need to be violated
any any other uh yes representative
Stapleton thank you Mr chair I I think
his long lawmakers we have the tendency
sometimes to drill down too deep and to
get into the weeds
and I've been guilty of that myself and
I'm trying to avoid that because we've
given discretion to the clerk the
medical documentation that they're
satisfied with is up to their discretion
as well and lets people let people do
the job that know how to do them instead
of us trying to micromanage
you know the last thing I say is I I
know I don't know if it was said it at
the hearing but I I know that at our at
that the Republican caucus somebody
mentioned that
um this Bill had been requested by the
clerks and that it was what they were
they are already doing this many clerks
are already doing this and apparently
without any problem and and the reason
that we got this legislation is that
somebody was concerned it's by basically
saying you know we've been doing this it
seems to be going okay but there we
there really is a question about whether
we actually have the authority to do it
maybe we should go to the legislature
and specifically confirm our Authority
so I guess what I'm I mean my point on
that is simply to say it appears from
all we've seen
that the clerks are appropriately
exercising their discretion as as you
mentioned and so I I don't see any
reason to think that wouldn't continue
so um
uh any any further comments on this uh
in this bill ready for a vote all right
I'll ask the clerk then to please call
the rule um
nope that's fine
so for SB 289 otpa Vice chairman Wallace
yes
rep Alexander yes rep Andrews YES Prep
testerman rep Stapleton Yes reptrip Yes
Prep Grayson yes clerkatab votes yes rep
Perez yes
rep Smith yes rep Oregon yes rep
dilorenzo
rep Kenny
rep page
rep Eden
rep divine yes rep Lanza yes
rep Manos
ripped her yes
chairman Lynn yes
motion passes 20 to 0. again this can go
on consent unless somebody objects
all right consent and I will uh write
the report
um
well you know I think on the screen
would you write the report on the
screening panel episode okay
okay
all right
um
next we turn to uh
SB 1
no reminder two oh I'm sorry 92.
right
SB 92 and
um for that I'd represent uh recognize
representative Kenny for a motion
thank you Mr chairman I move itl
is there a second I second the motion
all right all right uh representative
Kennedy would you like to speak to your
motion uh yeah sure um so this basically
adds functions to a position that really
doesn't have any duties currently and
they only make a hundred dollars a year
so I I just don't think this bill offers
productive changes and urge you to vote
itl thank you
um yes I
I've been a uh proponent of restoring
some of the doing something with the
office of register probate but this
um this isn't it and the judicial branch
was not in favor of it um
of the incumbent registers of probate
showed up if I recall at least not here
in the house meeting and there's also
also the salary is still fixed at a
hundred dollars a year even though
they'd be doing
more than they're doing now which is
essentially nothing except they have
the opportunity to work with the state
archive to preserve the historical
probate records so I would
so even though I've even though I've
been a friend of the registers of
probate and actually the office just
barely survived we had a constitutional
amendment where there was a floor fight
me and representative lard if a former
former Vice chair of this committee we
put up the good fight and we fell about
uh we need about 100 votes to stop the
Constitutional Amendment and we only got
about 25 so it was kind of a
kind of a fiasco but it did fail uh in
the vote amongst the people because
certain percentage of people just were
concerned about taking the right to vote
for any office away from the electorate
so that's an overly long anyway I
definitely don't
I think what's in this bill is uh not
worth pursuing so I'll be joining in the
rest of us and voting to kill voting the
itl dispel
anyone else wish to speak on this bill
seeing none I guess we're ready for a
vote the motion is to itl Senate Bill 92
and I'd ask the clerk to please call the
roll
base chairman Wallace yes
rep Alexander yes rep Andrews yes rep
testerman yes rep Stapleton yes reptrick
yes rep Grayson yes clerker tab votes
yes rep Perez
rep Smith yes
rep Oregon YES Prep De Lorenzo yes
rep Kenny yes
Brett Peach
rep Eaton
rep Divine yes
rep Lanza yes rep Manos yes Rapture yes
chairman Lynn yes motion passes 20-0
and again that uh can go on consent and
representative Kinney can I ask you to
write the report on that yes thank you
okay uh next we'll turn to uh
sb129
uh
second here
uh relative to payment of cost of
indigent persons involved in mediation
services and a chair recognized
representative Wallace for a motion
thank you Mr chairman I move ought to
pass
a second
briefly um
from my understanding and what was heard
in testimony in the hearing attorney had
from the Department of Justice made this
recommendation uh as it seems that the
bulk of the mediation
is not being uh sought by people of
Indian that are Indigent so we're
getting a much greater court costs uh to
handling the matters that they may be
involved in and this is more or less a
uh to streamline the operation uh
that's about it
all right anyone else wish to be yes
representative Manos
thank you Mr chair
um I'm going to support the motion for
OTP but my one hesitancy is that this
Deals Only with families with children
and there are certainly families who use
mediation who do not have children and
so I think it could potentially have a
two-tier a two-tier approach which I
don't think is productive but perhaps in
the future we can address families
without children
anyone else wish to comment
you know I guess the only thing I would
say is I you I mean I think you raised a
good point it if I recall Mr head's
testimony he was saying that the
uh apparently like up to three hours of
mediation is available that can be paid
for through the mediation fund and
the concern was that people that uh in
under the prior system where people had
to P people would be paid would have to
uh would have to pay uh people that were
either Indigent or very close to the
line would only use the minimum required
amount of mediation which I think might
have been an hour or something like that
in and so it might be that the that the
the court I don't know I don't know if
he specifically said that and I'm just
I'm speculating here but it might be
that that the cases that require more
than an hour are more likely to be ones
involve children and that that's where
you know that's why they limited here I
I don't know I'm not saying that that's
always true but that might be the reason
that they did it but certainly in the
future I think it might be this would be
something worth looking into if we try
you know if it should be expanded uh to
other other situations
but anyone else
wish to comment on SB 129 uh we've been
ready for a vote
I asked the clerk to call the roll
please chairman Wallace yes rep
Alexander rep Andrews yes rep testerman
yes rep Stapleton YES Prep trip yes rep
Grayson yes clerkatab votes yes rep
Perez
rep Smith
rep Oregon yes rep Delorenzo yes rep
Kenny yes rep page
rep Eaton
rep Divine yes rep lonza yes rep Manos
yes Rapture yes
chairman Lynn yes motion passes 20-0
again any reason that this can't go on
consent
or it'll be on consent and uh
representative Wallace can you write the
report on this yes sir thank you
all right
um
next is
SB 183 exempting certain phone calls
from the right to know lot and the chair
recognized representative Alexander for
a motion thank you Mr chair I move
um SB 183 ought to pass and I move
Amendment 1402h
is there a second
I second that
all right representative uh Alexander
would you wish to speak to your motion
yes um so this bill would exempt certain
calls from nine let me pull it up real
quick I have just the amendment in front
of me um certain calls from
um 911 calls from the right to no law
um but it adds in
um the caller illegal representative
with the
in my Amendment would also add the
subject of the call or a legal
representative
um so this was presented to the
committee as a compromise between
um
trial judges and the uh police or law
enforcement Community because it adds it
adds the exemption for limited purpose
release
um and and make sure that the um
records in which the subject of a
criminal investigation will be released
only after the criminal matter is
concluded so
um this amendment would just add the
subject of the call as well I mean if if
the committee remembers during the
public hearing I asked I gave the
scenario of if I got hit on mass Road
and Goffstown in representative Lanza
made the phone call about how the red
Jeep hit my silver Hyundai I didn't know
the call existed but maybe if I call the
police department and asked that
somebody made a call about me being the
subject of the call that my car was hit
then I'd be able to to use that in an
insurance request so I could get money
for my car being hit so so I believe
this this bill strengthens or this
amendment strengthens the bill and if
you see there is also a bipartisan or a
compromise on this amendment as well and
it's supported by the um the Chiefs as
well as the trial judges so I asked to
support it
anyone else wish to be heard on um yes
representative shop
thank you rep Alexander for your work on
this amendment I did also want to note
that I did contact the original sponsor
of the Bell Senator rashardi and I did
speak to her and she let me know kind of
who the stakeholders of this were and it
was as rep Alexander mentioned the
chiefs of police and I did personally
reach out to the president of the chief
chief of police
um
Chief brifonski from Bedford and I did
also reach out to the Department of
Safety
um
director and they were both in support
of this they did pass it along to the
other Chiefs to make sure that they
weren't missing something that was
potentially concerning but provided that
the exclusion remained in there about
the
um criminal activity they had figured
out a work a workflow to see if there
was a criminal investigation going on
and since
they were able to figure out a workflow
to make that work they didn't have any
concerns with this and they were fully
in support of it
anyone else wish to be heard on on this
all right so are we ready for a vote on
the amendment first
um and I think I can do that by show of
hand so all those in favor of the
amendment please raise your hand
any opposed
seeing none it's 20-0 on the in favor on
the amendment
and uh
are we now ready for a vote on the main
motion uh anyone else wish to speak
before we do that all right then I'd ask
the clerk to please call the roll on the
uh otpa
uh on Senate bill 183.
base chairman Wallace yes rep Alexander
yes rep Andrews yes rep testerman yeah
rep Stapleton YES Prep trip YES Prep
Grayson yes kirkutab votes yes rep Perez
rep Smith yes rep Horrigan yes rep
dilorenzo yes rep Kenny
rep page
rep eaten
rep Divine YES Prep lonza yes rep Manos
rept her yes
chairman Lynn yes
motion passes 20-0
again any reason it can't go on consent
and uh representative Alexander could I
ask you to write the report on this
please yes thank you
um next we're on to
um Senate Bill 250
relative to remote participation in
government meetings and I represent uh
recognize representative Tripp for a
motion
thank you Mr chair I moved in expedient
to legislate is there a second I'll
second
motion has been made and seconded uh
representative you wish to speak to your
motion yes I do please
this uh bill is
a pretty good example of
a solution looking for a problem in my
opinion uh it's uh an example of
codifying something that uh that the
really only complicates a fairly simple
matter
uh
and uh it actually does
it does not improve
uh
the law thank you anyone else wish to
speak to uh represent to uh SB 250.
all right are we ready for a vote theft
um I would ask the clerk to please call
the roll
the motion of itl for SB 250 Vice
chairman Wallace yes rep Alexander rep
Andrews yes rep testerman rep Stapleton
yes reptrick yes rep Grayson yes clerker
tap votes yes Rhett Perez yes
rep Smith yes rep Horrigan yes rep D
Lorenzo yes rep Kenny yes rep page
rep eaten
rep Divine yes rep Lanza yes rep Manos
yes repturer yes
chairman Lynn yes motion passes 20-0
again any reason this can't go on
consent
I've seen none and representative Tripp
could I ask you to write a report on
this
yes thank you
all right
um what I'd like to do uh just be just
in the interest of expediency I'd like
to skip 255 for the moment and move on
to uh SB 264 which I think will probably
entail less less discussion uh and I'm
going to rep recognize representative
Manos for a motion
thank you Mr chair I move um OTP on this
uh on this bill
um this bill do we have a second I'll
second all right representative Mass
would you like to speak to your motion
yes I would Mr chair thank you
um this bill to a large extent is a
housekeeping Bill and to a large extent
um adds clarification to the statute and
certainty to the statute I think uh also
it improves the existing legislation by
recognizing that parent
that agreed upon carrier agreements I
don't have the terminology right but uh
carrier agreements
um
can substantially comply with the
statute rather than literally comply
with the statute and the purpose of that
is so that practitioners in this area of
law who make
um
or agreements that don't technically
comply with the law
would substantially comply with it and
therefore lead to certainty in the
agreements I think practitioners who may
be practice in other states or who make
small technical errors
that those agreements should continue to
be recognized and so I support this
legislation
thank you thank you anyone else wish to
speak yes representative greeson thank
you Mr chair after I read through this
again there was a on page five
Section 8 Roman numeral eight excuse me
is in addition to the
to the current law and it says nothing
in this chapter is intended to abrogate
any rights of the resulting child to
pursue any legally authorized action and
I'm wondering what this is supposed to
mean what its intent is
why it was added
it just it jumped out of me and raised
I'm sorry you know what could you refer
me again to watch where page five Roman
numeral eight Roman numeral eight okay
that's the bottom of the page
foreign
you know I my I I don't know this for a
fact but my inclination is that what
this is intended to do is just to make
it in other words if they're
if there was
a right
for example if a if a if a child had
let me sort of give this example if a if
a child let's suppose that a child were
was injured in utero by somebody
assaulting the mother and it and not
only injured the mother but injured the
child
um the child may very well have made
very well I don't I'm not you know I
haven't researched this issue it's just
sort of I'm speaking kind of
extemporaneously but the child might
well have
an action
um once the child is born might well
have an action against the whoever
injured whoever injured the whoever
injured it
um
my my suspicion is that this was just
added to say that
the nothing the fact that they're that
the child might be the product of of uh
artificial insemination does not in any
way abrogate you know rights that
otherwise existed so that's I that might
that's my suspicion is that this is just
the you know sort of safety net don't
don't uh nothing that nothing that in
the the hole in vitro fertilization that
kind of thing surrogate parentage not is
not intended to diminish any rights that
the child would otherwise have I that's
that's the way I sort of read it
is that a legal question now
is that even in question now under
current law
I don't I don't know if I mean I may I I
don't but I guess somebody somebody I
assume must have thought that maybe it
could be and so that was uh you know I
just read this as sort of a safety valve
kind of thing not nobody in other words
I don't know how valid this argument
would be but I guess somebody might have
been worried that
somebody would say
you know as a defense May in the example
I gave somebody might say as a defense
well no that might that doesn't apply
here because this child was born in us
out of a surrog as he said surrogacy
situation I don't think that argument
would carry much water but maybe
somebody was concerned that you know
let's let's let's nail this down
completely to make sure that we that it
can't be read that way
so that I mean I I don't I guess I I
guess what I would say is I don't see
how it would be harmful since it doesn't
purport to create
any kind of new rights
and I guess I should say is there if
there's anybody here on 264 that has is
you know more is is an expert in this
area and you have something to say
please uh
would live
somebody's coming ah okay
yeah I'm sorry could you just tell us
who you are
hi my name is Catherine Tucker I'm an
attorney in the Concord area and I
practice in this field of Law and I just
want to say that that was there were
some concerns brought up by um Senator
Carson about what rights the fetus would
or wouldn't have and so the way we
addressed it is that we're not changing
whatever rights the fetus does or
doesn't have are not going to be
impacted by this particular bill
whatever they are stay in place as as is
under current law
all right any anybody anyone have any
questions
um for this for this uh an effective
witness thank you very much I appreciate
your your input on this thank you all
right any other comments on 264.
right
um are we ready for a vote
then I asked the clerk to please call
the roll
for SB 264 on the motion about to pass
Vice chair Wallace yes
rep Alexander rep Andrews yes rep
testerman
rep Stapleton yes reptrip yes rep
Grayson yes clerkatab votes yes rep
Perez yes
rep Smith yes rep Horgan yes rep D
Lorenzo yes
rep Kenny yes rep page
rep Eaton
rep Divine yes rep Lanza yes rep Manos
yes
repter yes
chairman Lynn yes motion passes 20-0
all right again consent
um all right and representative Manos
can I ask you to uh write the report
certainly Mr turd thank you
um
all right now we'll turn to uh rep uh HB
I'm sorry SB 255 and the chair uh
recognizes uh representative Smith for a
motion
thank you Mr chair imove retain on House
Bill 255. you're a second second
has been made and seconded
representative Smith would you like to
speak to your motion yes I would like to
speak to my motion this is an incredibly
timely bill
it is a very important bill
we cannot open a newspaper I'm probably
the only one here who still reads
newspapers but
um okay well maybe there's more do when
it when they actually managed to deliver
it to me uh
uh without understanding how relevant
this issue is and how unbelievably
complicated it is and for
um while we understand that other states
have moved ahead
um on legislation that is pretty close
to this and so we're not out there on
there on our own
nonetheless New Hampshire likes to march
to its own drummer and to be
particularly careful since we are such a
small state and it is easy for everyone
in the state to be affected and if we
were Cavalier in our decisions
it could come back to haunt us
um
I personally believe this should be a
federal issue I am glad that there are
other states coming forward with
versions of this and hope that that will
encourage uh the government in
Washington to recognize that they should
step up to the plate
but that not being the case now I would
like to make sure
that the questions that we have and some
of us many of us have questions that
aren't the same which in itself is an
indication of how complex it is that we
in effect delay our action on this for
six months which is what it would be
with the expectation that the committee
would work
um
diligently with uh all interested
parties in the legislature and out in
order to make sure that what New
Hampshire produces is the best possible
bill
that we could produce for this state
thank you Mr chair all right other
people wish to speak representative horn
um yes I mean this issue isn't going
away and this bill isn't going away
there's a broad
there's a broad Coalition which is
working on it and this was certainly a
vast improvement over
the previous bills because at least it
did take the interests of the
you know the online
the industry the information Services
the online industry into account lots of
services we use
to reserve a trade-off where we give
away a little bit of our private
information in exchange for a free or
low-cost service and that's um
that's just when the underpinnings of
our economy and certainly needs to be
certainly needs to be regulated but I'm
not sure if this bill
is the right vehicle to do it and but
people are working on it will be
improved and it does have both users and
providers and I've been a
provider internet services on a very
very tiny scale I still have a website I
still know what they call like virtual
land in the virtual world second life
and as a
provider I have
I've I actually have the right I have to
protect the I mean I've like protect the
privacy of the people who are there but
also I have the right to know who's you
know who's using the uh server that I'm
leasing who's using who's on the virtual
land and in some cases uh
those can be
those can be uh those can be abused you
know there's
terrorists child pornographers all kinds
of Bad actors and there's also just uh
you know
scam artists on there so I have to write
and actually even the duty to a certain
extent to uh
uh protect protect protect my interests
and that involves uh at least some
extent having some idea of who it is
who's using my little bit of bandwidth
that I'm I'm making available so that's
uh obviously I was about like one
trillionth the scale of Microsoft who
came to talk to us but I do
at least sort of understand that there's
you know there's rights and there's
concerns on the other side of the scale
not just for the users so
um
anyway I'm sure this group is working
the bill will be working on new new
versions of it anyway this as we I guess
it's not part of the uniform law
commission but it is through a similar
process I think certainly retaining it
over the summer to look at the issue a
little bit more depth is definitely the
appropriate thing to do at this time and
I'll vote for that motion thanks other
people wish to speak
um representative Turner uh yeah um I I
also uh favor the idea of retain for
this bill for for a couple of different
reasons some related to sort of the
language of the bill and particularly we
heard some conflicting testimony around
the scope of of what organizations would
be covered you know whether it's a
hundred thousand New Hampshire residents
or a hundred thousand
um uh total users of these bills and
some other technical issues my other
concern is logistically we definitely
heard from the Attorney General's office
that they're overburdened as it is and
the fiscal note on this basically
suggests that this could add significant
additional burden and and we learned
that
that they're the the fund that would
support this is capped and they don't
really have the ability to to get the
resources to act on it even if they had
the authority so I think for those
reasons I would like to see us work on
on the bill further acknowledging that
that there's there is a real issue and
and to the urgency I believe is is less
in that because other states are moving
forward we heard that many of the
providers
um of these resources are already having
to put steps in place to comply with
other state rules that move us closer
other yes representative
so I had debated back and forth for
similar reasons expressed on this bill
however ultimately I I did like the
amendment that chairman Lane had come up
with you know clarifying that the users
per year I did think that addressed that
issue and I think
while we'd like to think we're protected
by what other states have we have no
way of enforcing any of it because it's
not our statue and I think adding this
isn't going to do any harm but yes I do
agree that the Attorney General's office
may not necessarily have the capacity to
enforce something like this but let's
say there were to be parties that were
harmed from this
at that point they would at least have
the authority
to do something right now nothing could
happen if somebody was harmed and I
think this committee has a lot of other
work over the summer that
perhaps is more relevant to the current
time in terms of like the the HRC like
that needs a lot of work I think
if at some point the federal government
is to put something in we can always
repeal our statue or if this statue
wasn't working we could always add
something in but I don't see at least if
we put something in there is something
that you providing some sort of
protection that the Attorney General
could do something if somebody were to
be harmed and
I I think leaving it behind I guess just
doesn't allow us any course of action at
all if something were to happen and I I
know there was discussion about private
right of action and I think you know at
first I was in favor of it but then
ultimately
as I discussed it further it came to
light that well a lot of times when that
happens it's really attorneys who are
getting rich off of that right and
they're doing class action lawsuits and
it's not actually the person who's even
harmed that's even benefiting off of it
um and so I wouldn't want that to happen
and at the same time if you made it
smaller that only that person could go
after for a private right of action then
there's also the concern of are we going
to have a bunch of you know frivolous
lawsuits where you know Facebook and
Microsoft who aren't even located in New
Hampshire would be forced to either send
somebody to respond on their behalf or
potentially have a default judgment
issued against them and so I can see why
the private action right of action
wasn't in there but I do like at least
the AG's office could do something and
he could potentially get the damages for
somebody if if something were to happen
so
um I personally would
support
um
passing
um passing it with the amendment that
that replyn has provided and I
I just think that that's worth
considering rather than putting it off
um and retaining it because I'm not sure
what we can really make better in the
next six months so thank you
um
yes representative Alexander thank you
Mr chair I like to agree with my friend
representative Smith from Durham as much
as I can and I actually do agree with
her in this situation
um there's another bill that this
committee retained regarding privacy and
that dealt primarily with governmental
units and I feel pretty strongly that if
we're going to regulate private business
we should start by regulating ourselves
first so I'd like to see it retained and
maybe
um I'm sure there'll be a lot more
people at the hearing if we add
government units right now it's just
private but I'd like to see it retain as
well thank you all right uh other
comment uh representative I'm sorry
representative Andrew yes
thank you Mr chair I am very happy we
have the motion to retain this bill I
believe there's very many
unanswered questions
and I concur with everything
representative Smith said
we need to answer these questions and in
the ultimate end
my only thing is protecting the people
of New Hampshire other than that I don't
care about the big companies I'm sorry
I don't care about the big companies and
you know what they're doing and what
they aren't doing I'm only concerned
with the people of New Hampshire and I
don't agree with maybe passing something
and then make changes because sometimes
when we pass things we eat words after
and sometimes things can't be changed so
I'm very happy that we're going to vote
to retain thank you
so representative Stapleton
thank you Mr chair um
I'm in favor of a retain but I
appreciate the remarks of Representative
guptab on the right of action
um
the bill is is written toward the AG's
office handling the complaint as the
sole Focus for this
I think that there needs some work to
see if there's room for private right of
action or if not class action
so I think that needs work to reconcile
those interests on the other thing that
I was Disturbed with was the lack of any
monetary evaluation in the financial
note
and I was able to pick up the minutes
from the Senate hearing and um
Brandon garage a senior Assistant
Attorney General at the New Hampshire
um
Attorney General's office had had this
to say
if said he said if this bill were passed
into law today given the current makeup
of the consumer protection and
Anti-Trust Bureau
this would be an impossible Bill to
enforce the consumer protection and
antitrust Bureau is responsible for the
review and response to thousands of
consumer complaints that are received
each year
they are also responsible for
investigating proposed mergers in the
state
he believed
he believed that this entirely new
chapter would only add on to the
responsibilities of the consumer
protection and Anti-Trust Bureau
which could not be effectively enforced
without additional resources he said the
additional resources would take the form
of additional staff additional attorneys
and at least one more investigator
so essentially you'd have to create
somewhat of a bureau or Commission
and from zero on the FN it could be a
million or whatever
and and I think for that reason and the
reconciling of
AG handle and right of
right of action and class action that we
we should work on this further with a
retained
then other other Comics uh
representative tur yeah I I just wanted
to sort of also lift up
um what representative could have
um said uh I think the amendment which
assuming if we go toward a routine I
guess we're not going to hear that
um moves things forward the only
clarification I wanted to make
um on that is we have the term consumer
in you know still in the language and in
in that Amendment and the the bill
defines consumer as a New Hampshire
resident and I think we had heard during
the the
um
testimony that the true intent was a
hundred thousand
um consumers or a hundred thousand users
across their entire scope of business
otherwise this would would lead to a
very narrow
um scope that that this pertains to so I
just wanted to clarify uh what I was
saying earlier about about that that
hundred thousand limit it wasn't the
number as much as it was
um that term consumer and whether that
can term consumers really what what we
should have but uh again still speaking
in favor of retaining
right right representative Smith
thank you perhaps nothing else needs to
be said but um I do want to mention two
things first
um in terms of the the testimony that
representative Singleton just
read to us
um that in itself indicates that this
committee the Judiciary Committee might
be the appropriate source for
legislation either in this bill or in
another bill that would address issues
that have come before us concerning the
ability of the consumer
division of the AG's office to meet the
needs of the state in the most effective
way and it's one more indication of the
benefits of retaining and
um I I do want to make one other comment
about
um
representative caltex comments
um and perhaps it comes from having been
married to an attorney for almost 50
years
um but there certainly are attorneys who
behave inappropriately just as there are
Physicians who behave inappropriately
and I would hope that this committee
would not begin by assuming that
um
attorneys would just be in it that all
attorneys would just be in this for the
money and
um
I want to make sure that we help keep
everybody honest thank you
right so uh representative Qatar
I appreciate your your comments rep
Smith and I just I wanted to clarify I
wasn't meeting any insult towards any
attorneys and I apologize if it did come
across that way we have several
attorneys on our committee here that I
am very fond of um and I would not mean
to insult them I just I simply meant
that in the purpose of of some of the
class action lawsuits that have that
have come out
um but but no I certainly don't think
that the majority of attorneys are are
that way so I just wanted to clarify
thank you
so uh
yeah but I think well I think I'm I'm
going to speak and then I'll let you uh
so I guess I would say
from the comments I've heard I I have to
say honestly I'm I'm disappointed
because I share representative kutab's
view I would vote I'm going to vote
against the the motion to retain because
I think the bill should be passed
um as with with my proposed amendments
and what I what I guess I'd ask you to
to think about I mean maybe that I'm not
going to change anybody's mind but
this this bill particularly with the
Amendments it now mirrors as I
understand it the Connecticut bill which
in turn mirrors the Virginia and
Colorado Bill almost almost uh almost
word for word I mean their their systems
of of organizing statutes may be
different but but basically it's it's
the same
and so what it
what this says to me is a couple of
things first of all I completely agree
that this is a complicated bill it's got
lots of sections and you know if you're
if you're reading it you have to kind of
keep going back well what okay so does
this imply or not because maybe maybe it
comes within this exception or something
like that it is complicated I don't deny
that but what I would say and I ask you
to think about is
this as we heard at as we saw at the
hearing this bill has been worked on and
and
um considered and adopted
uh by by some people who seem to me to
be pretty smart and pretty pretty
knowledgeable in this area and and I
think did a pretty thorough job of
putting this together and it's also been
considered by a number of other
legislative bodies and I guess I can't
help noting it seemed it seems like
legislative bodies that are on both
sides of the spectrum of Connecticut on
the one hand and I as I understand it
Montana and uh Indiana have uh as I if I
I think I've got this corrected Montana
and Montana and I think it's Indiana the
bills have gone through the legislature
both houses and are waiting for the
Governor's signature as I understand it
so and plus you have Virginia it's
passed in Virginia which I guess is now
I think is is in Republican hands or at
least the governor in one house is in
Republican hands so anyway that suggests
to me that this is sort of this has sort
of been reviewed
pretty extensively by people with
differing philosophies and have been has
been found to be an appropriate
um appropriate legislation the other
thing that I guess I would I would say
is is this I think
that you um
one of the things that we should
consider is that even if this bill is
not perfect it does advance the ball it
seems to me in the right direction in
that it you know right now
the protections that are
provided to consumers in this bill don't
exist so if we if we do if we do nothing
the the law stays the same and there is
less privacy protection than there would
be with this bill
um
with regard to the to the issue I you
know I think representative my my
understanding is that this bill would be
pretty narrow because I think
I think it does it does uh it does mean
at least with with the amendment that
I've proposed it does mean that this
bill applies to New Hampshire business
it applies to a business
that in the prior year
processed a hundred thousand consumers
New Hampshire consumers so that you know
that may make it relatively relatively
narrow
um which means that you know which which
means I guess that to the extent
that I and I was one of these that had
concerns about you know is this is this
somehow an effort by big business to to
cap to do something that they can afford
to do but will be will really hurt small
business
um I think that that the fact that it is
pretty narrow tends to suggest that you
know there will be a lot of small and
medium-sized businesses in New Hampshire
that will not be covered by this and so
that to me that sort of diminishes the
argument that this is really an effort
by big business to do something that
will excuse my language will sort of
screw smaller smaller mid-sized business
it seems to me that that that
um
the the the
applicability section sort of reduces
that chance
um
I know that there was a there was an
issue raised as to
um and the original bill that the the
Attorney General was required to give an
opera an option to cure for any
violation without limitation and that
was there was a question I think some
people had a question about whether that
you know whether that was fair should
that be be allowed to happen and so I
the amendment that I would propose
change that to say that the requirement
of gr of granting an option to cure as a
you know that you had to do that only
applied to the first year so that this
this would you know if if this took
effect as it was as it is proposed on
January 1st of 2025 for that year
the year 2025 the Attorney General would
have to give an option to cure but after
that it would be it would be
discretionary so the Attorney General
could decide
using the factors that are listed in the
bill whether or not it was appropriate
to offer an opportunity uh to cure
um
and then with the lastly with regards
and I know this has been an issue with
regard to the issue of a private cause
of action
I have to say that that is something
that I feel very strongly about and I
would I would not be able to support
this bill if it had if it included a
private cause of action because
particularly
in this area it seems to me that that
the the
that the violation if there's a
violation of this statute if this
statute were enacted and there were a
violation of this statute my sense is
that in the overwhelming majority of
cases there would be little or no damage
and if there was a private cause of
action the only thing that somebody
would be trying would really be trying
to get is the thousand dollars that uh
that is the the sort of penalty for lack
of a better term that you're entitled to
under the consumer protection act even
if you don't have any real damages that
those would be the types of of cases
that would be predominantly
um the the uh what would be what would
be sought and so that people would not
uh and and I think that there would
there could be an incentive as I've I've
done some arbitration since I retired
and I'd sort of seen that this kind of
thing happens there would be class
actions for Leo with you know people
that suffered really little damages but
there were a lot of them and so there
were you know in the end what what often
happens in those cases is you know uh
the the quote-unquote victims end up
recovering fifteen dollars and uh the
attorneys recover hundreds of thousands
of dollars in legal fees uh and that
just doesn't seem to me to be a product
active uh situation
I would agree however that there could
be there could be a few cases in which
people were armed very seriously by
something that violated the statute but
the thing I would you know I would I
would ask you to consider is
that those people are not left without a
remedy because the Attorney General is
allowed to bring actions and I would
seem to me that that kind of case where
somebody was really armed very
significantly their reputation was
publicly ruined or something something
else you know happened even more
egregious than that perhaps physical
harm to somebody or whatever
um
that would be the kind of situation
where the Attorney General would be
likely to exercise his his authority to
bring an action and and could could
recover damages which could then be uh
available to the person so I I don't
think it's it's fair to say that
somebody would be left people that are
injured would be left remedy-less unless
there was a private cause of action
so I guess I'm not gonna I don't want to
go on forever and I know I've probably
spoken too long already I hope you'll
think about the the points I've made
um and I I would encourage you to vote
against the motion to retain so that
another motion could be made and that
mode my motion would be to ought to pass
with the Amendments that that I've
proposed and if you know I that's that's
my pitch I I understand it may be a
losing cause and if I lose and I will
happily participate in the retent in the
in working on the bill further during
the retain period but I think it would
be better to pass it now and so I hope
you'll I hope you'll think about that
representative Horgan well thank you for
thanks for letting me thank you for
letting me speak um the clerk reminded
me that there's actually a class action
suit going around something with people
or Facebook messages I've been a
beneficiary of several of those over the
year and actually the 15 check is
about 10 times bigger than what you
usually get out of these things and I
think one of them actually was in my
role as a web service provider that I
was leasing out a few inches of space on
my website to Google to use for their ad
services and there's some sort of class
action suit involved with that and I got
and even then it was less than fifteen
dollars and it was so a little money I
forgotten what it is but um
mostly just want to say is the the
online industry the providers they're
well aware of the consumers concerns
these people aren't aren't Saints but
they do know that people are worried
about them and they're of course worried
about
themselves being the target of like
illegal activity and abuse so I think uh
at least to some extent the market and
there will be need to be more guidance
from the law but I think the market uh
does regulate itself to a certain extent
and also uh
what was I going to say oh and um
also they're I think they're all pretty
well aware of how fragile they're they
there's always a few providers you've
seen the monopolies but I think they're
all aware and some of them do hang on
for year after year like Microsoft came
to visit us and apple but for the most
part
um most part these entities come and go
every year is and the people who
operated them were hopefully well aware
of how that they're 10 10 years fragile
and one of the things that often does
them in is
either privacy or accountability
concerns as we've seen with uh
will actually use Facebook to
communicate with a member of this
Committee just this morning but um you
know Facebook has taken a big hit in the
last few months or years and Twitter is
also uh it's not quite blowing up as
spectacularly as their owner's SpaceX
rocket but that too is blown up because
the number of probably bad decisions
that have been made so they're all I
think these you know they
the large and small entrepreneurs in
that space are what right did I say
something wrong then no no it's just
it's going to be going a little bit a
little bit away anyway anyway I think so
they're well aware that this is a uh
that they need they're well aware that
they need us consumers and they're
probably pretty well aware of what our
concerns are so they will beat him at
least part ways so I don't think it's
and the urgency with this bill and I
think certainly we're retaining it is an
excellent idea I think thanks
anyone else wish to yes representative
Stapleton thank you Mr chair
um
the Connecticut form was passed in the
spring of 2022 so it's a fairly recent
law
and um I believe that
you know if we delay this for six months
to work on it we're not going to fall
off the cliff with any really dangerous
sort of occurrences but the six months
gives us time to look into
what's happened in Connecticut are there
some pitfalls are there some nuances are
there some revisions that they have come
across in the limited time to look at it
to to make a better product and to avoid
things that we didn't comprehend and
could maybe make make a better product
by relying on the other State's
experiences that have passed the law
are there anyone else which do you speak
all right so you know and I guess we're
ready to have uh or vote on the motion
to retain
Vice chairman Wallace yes
rep Alexander yes rep Andrews no us
rep testerman
rep Stapleton yes rap trap YES Prep
Grayson no
perk catab votes now rep Perez
rep Smith yes
rep Oregon yes rep D Lorenzo yes
rep Kenny yes
prep page no
rep Eden
rep Divine no
replanza no
rep Manos yes
rep Terror yes
chairman Lynn no
motion passes 13 to 7.
okay all right
okay
all right
all right now we don't since it's being
retained we don't need a report all
right
um why is there any other business that
we need to uh
deal with
all right so we're
we're we've worked very efficiently it
seems to be so uh do you want to remind
considering that oh you might want to
get the reports in oh oh yeah you know
what I'm sorry you know what can I just
ask for that it seems like I think
everything is consent except uh the one
we retain so can you get can I ask
everybody to get your reports into me by
the end of the day today I mean when I
say the end of the day like tonight you
know what I mean that gives you 12 hours
is it going to be really short reports
all right so all right so here's what
I'll do I'm I'm a nice guy so 10 o'clock
tomorrow morning by 10 o'clock tomorrow
morning you have to be in session at
nine oh right I forgot about it
all right so I'll leave it get them to
me by tomorrow morning at 10 and that
that means you're gonna have to do them
early because you're gonna because we're
gonna you're gonna have to be here uh
the other thing I want to remind
remember we have one more bill that
we're having a hearing on on a on a non
or
I guess it's somewhat's your main
Amendment
um
well I I might take issue with that at
least a little bit but germainish
jermaine-ish that's it uh nine o'clock
uh uh next Wednesday and then we're
gonna exec that at 10 at 10 30. because
that's the it turns out that's the one
bill we have to get in because I think
that's got to go to finance that's an
early bill so um other than that um I'll
see you all tomorrow and and
um
oh I'm sorry reply yes
we have to because we have to have a
hearing we have to have a hearing on it
and we have we have to give we had to
give notice that's the that's the
problem
that's the problem yeah
all right all right
what's that now hold on I I you know I
would have preferred it to go the other
way that's all right
this
I'm not going to get this isn't
something that leadership had
this at all
I like well there was a you know if
somebody was if they were pressing
really hard right right right right yeah
no good but
please
okay
I apologize